ja wir kommen zur vierten sitzung in der
wir uns mit johann august teil durch
ulrich befassen einem nicht so ganz
bekannten oder vielleicht sogar besser
gesagt gar nicht bekannten denker
kleineren vermeintlich denker der nach
kritischen debatte des sogenannten früh
kann tennis muss wir haben jetzt in der
heutigen sitzung und ein paar leitfragen
überlegt wie bewertet ulrich kann's
freiheits theorie wie interpretiert
unrecht kann zwei theorien
das ist eine andere frage und inwiefern
ist seine interpretation problematisch
inwiefern leicht ulrich eigenständig
fand ganz theorie ab inwiefern ist seine
eigene theorie problematisch wir müssen
immer bedenken die sind nach kantischen
denken auch die kleineren die sind jetzt
nicht nur bloße adepten oder bluse
schüler von kant sondern die haben schon
einen eigenen hintergrund teilweise und
vor diesem hintergrund interpretieren
sie kann's theorie konnten sie sind ja
teilweise auch sehr kritisch mit
gegangen so sagt dieser herr ulrich also
aus und er hat ein buch geschrieben mit
dem titel triologie erneut theologie
oder über freiheit und notwendigkeit und
jetzt kann man sich natürlich schon mal
hier
das ganze anschauen leute biologie was
steckt da drin also da steckt einerseits
erläuter wir das ist griechisch und
heißt freiheit
und eben noch die logi das ist der logos
oder die logik das ist die lehre an das
ist die freiheit lehre sozusagen und im
untertitel nennt er sie über freiheit
und notwendigkeit hier kann man sehr
schön erkennen dass es hier um die frage
nach kompatibel ist muss oder
inkompatibilität nach heutiger
terminologie
und wir werden jetzt gleich sehen dass
ullrich in seinem werk begriffe einführt
die über die damalige zeit hinaus weisen
ich werde jetzt genau noch darauf
eingehen erst mal sage ich noch etwas zu
seiner biografie als er war professor
für philosophie an der universität jena
er war stark vom leibniz- wolfen
rationalismus beeinflusst leibnitz
kennen sie alle das ist einer der
wichtigsten rationalisten die also die
vernunft ganz stark gemacht haben und
wolf war auch ein rationalist der
sogenannten deutschen schul philosophie
und die gemeinsamkeit beider denker
besteht darin dass sie einen starken
determinismus vertreten haben zumindest
leibnitz danach leitet ist alles
determiniert und zwar nach dem satz des
zureichenden grundes und jetzt kann man
sich schon denken welche probleme darauf
anzukommen wenn eben alles determiniert
ist dann haben wir ein bisschen probleme
mit der freiheit und zwar deswegen weil
wir immer so die intuition haben
freiheit er hat auch sein in
deterministische moment ja und nach
leibnitz muss also freiheit ganz
rational deterministisch geklärt werden
können nach diesem sozialistischen
ideale der völligen bestimmung nur das
was bestimmtes kann man auch erklären
rational verstehen so und das ist dieser
hintergrund von diesem herrn röhrig in
dieser ideologie von 1788 der
argumentierte eben aus dieser sicht
dieses leitbild zur rationalismus gegen
die kante moralphilosophie es soll aber
nicht seine theorie nur darauf
reduzieren auf diesen hintergrund diesen
nationalistischen hintergrund sondern
wir sollten eben auch schauen
macht jetzt welche systematische
angebote inwiefern kritisiert erkannt zu
recht wieder zu unrecht wie viel findet
er lösungen zu problemen die bei kant
angelegt und wir haben eben nach seiner
theorie das ist so konnte nur die wahl
zwischen determinismus und in der termin
ismus menschliche handlungen und wie wir
hier so schon zehn röhrig ist eine der
ersten der diesen begriff des in
determinismus einführt also dieser
begriff ist ja häufig auch in der
neueren debatte ist geprägt worden
jetzt kann man also zusammenfassend
sagen dass ullrich einen start mit ihm
kompatibel ismus bezüglich menschlicher
freiheit vertritt also determinismus
determinismus lassen sich nicht
vereinbaren wie es kann tja vorhatte und
werde ich jedenfalls hatte das bekannt
ein kompatibles muss genannt kann man
sich großer über das unterhalten wie ob
es wirklich ein kompatibles muss ist
jedenfalls kann spricht immer wieder
davon dass er beide sachen vereinigen
möchte und da ist bestreitet jetzt
ulrich seinem text triologie sie haben
jetzt vor sich einen text der bislang
nur oder größtenteils nur in
frakturschrift vorlag und diesen text
den sie jetzt hier präsentiert bekommen
den werden sie dann auch finden in einer
edition die ich zusammen mit einem
anderen forscher heraus gebe und die
bald in meiner verlag erscheinen würde
ich wäre dann auch unten in der
beschreibung des videos bei zeit die
beschreibung einmal so und jetzt seit
der folgendes dieser herr ulrich
notwendigkeit von allen dem was an
bereits über diesen begriff in der logik
metaphysik und moral weitläufige gesagt
wird hat man sich hier nur an folgendes
zu erinnern
die notwendigkeit ist entweder
physischer natur notwendigkeit oder
sittlich durch jeden ausdruck also durch
die physische natur die notwendigkeit
wollen mit den gedanken ein deuten dass
beisetzung gewisse umstände etwas an
das bleibt nicht gesetzt wird und das
gegenteil unter vollkommen denselben
umständen nicht möglich ist wobei man
noch die äußere und innere mit ihren
gatten den sälen und blinden oder
politischen notwendigkeit zu
unterscheiden hat also was er hier sagt
ist das wenn gewisse umstände gegeben
sind das wird auch in der gegenwärtig
analytischen philosophie so gemacht also
wenn ein welt zustand wie 00 angenommen
wird und die naturgesetze gelten dann
muss immer unter diesem vorbedingung
dasselbe heraus kommt und dann kann man
nicht trotz dieser vorgaben zu
unterschiedlichen ergebnissen kommen das
legt eine freiheit der wahl dass man
unter denselben bedingungen immer auch
anders entscheiden können und das
bestreitet jetzt dieser starke
determinismus und er geht jetzt aber
nicht nur auf diese natur notwendigkeit
ein auf die kante auch eingegangen war
es dann eher und das unterscheidet ihn
jetzt von kant er spricht jetzt hier
auch von einer sittlichen notwendigkeit
und das hier beginnt jetzt ein bisschen
diese eigene interpretation kann hätten
die notwendigkeit so in zwei arten
geteilt wohl auch immer wieder davon
spricht das ist eine moralische
notwendigkeit gibt sittlich und
natürlich das macht jetzt ullrich sagt
die sittliche notwendigkeit was ist mit
der die ist der gedanke oder die
erkenntnis unserer vernunft dass etwas
geschehen solle ob es gleich deswegen
noch nicht alle mal wirklich sind wie
wir das gegenteil davon geschieht das
heißt ob gleich nach der erfahrung
dieser gedanke von sollen noch nicht
alle mal wenn es
nun zur wirklichen aus gebunden kommt
die nötige wirksamkeit hat das feste
wollen hervorzubringen
nicht alle mal hinlänglich kausalität
häusern wird aber die vorstellung der
sittlichen notwendigkeit oder das sollen
ist so wirksam dass sie das feste wollen
selbst hervorbringt und die
entgegengesetzten reiz nicht vermögen so
ist das entstehen eines solchen
schlosses beisetzung jena nach erlangten
wirksamkeit des gedankens ich soll auch
wahre natur notwendigkeit also hier
macht er jetzt folgendes er
identifiziert jetzt hier weicht er
wirklich von kant ab die sittliche
notwendigkeit mit der natur
notwendigkeit als er sagt im endeffekt
sind beide notwendigkeit eigentlich
identisch
vielleicht hat er jetzt ein anderer
natur begriff das ist die frage
aber im endeffekt kommt aufs selbe raus
wir sind beide male nicht frei oder
zumindest determiniert im strengen sinne
das lesen wir mal weiter
also noch dazu sagt nächsten zitat hatte
auch ein interessante these nicht mehr
vorlesen
er sagt folgendes und ebenso wenn die
erfahrung lehrt dass der gedanke von
sollen bei einem bestimmten objekt in
einem bestimmten fall nicht die nötige
wirksamkeit äußert wenn es von demis
video million apropos mdt rio seco also
das heißt ich sehe und billige das
bessere folge aber dem schlechteren so
hat auch dieses seine entscheidenden
gründe warum ist jetzt so und nicht
anders geht es ist auch hier natur
notwendigkeit also natur notwendigkeit
ist einfach diese man könnte auch sagen
mit
ausgesprochen natur notwendigkeit ist
jetzt meine interpretation ist einfach
das was dem satz vom zureichenden grunde
folgt das ist auf den satz von zwei
gründe zurückzuführen
er lautet eben alles hat eine ursache
es gibt nichts was keine ursache hat und
dass hier sehen wir jetzt ein bisschen
diese leibchen hintergründe
ok also erkannt hat er von einer
moralischen notwendigkeit gesprochen
also zwei arten von determination
angenommen und ulrich zeit gibt es im
endeffekt ist es doch dieselbe zufall
jetzt kommt er auf den zufall zu
sprechen ohne mich jetzt auf die
zweideutigkeiten des ausdrucks
einzulassen verstehe ich unter zu
verleihen entstehen ein werden welches
keine entscheidenden gründe hat sondern
wo unter vollkommen denselben umstellen
da etwas geschah
ebenso gut das gegenteil geschehen
konnte denke dass dieser begriff dem
allgemein ssten rede gebraucht gemäss
sei also wenn hier sagt der zufall ist
dass es keine entscheidenden gründe hat
als also nicht dem satz des zu reichen
grundes folgt und eben die unter
denselben umständen das jetzt wenig eben
immer auch das gegenteil hätte erfolgen
können also praktisch so wie 0 in diese
richtungen also trotzdem beide zustände
dieselben sind wie nur dass jetzt die
welt 0
man kann auch sagen plus die l 0 also
plus die naturgesetze die kamera auch
noch mit herein obwohl das so war
können wir uns und denselben umständen
zum beispiel in zwei verschiedene
handlungsoptionen stilrichtungen wegen
und das wäre jetzt der zufall während
eben das andere modell was ihr leben
bevorzugt das hier ist die laster zu
nehmen dass wir eben wenn man sie
entscheiden dann kümmern jemand nur in
diese richtung gehen eine
entgegengesetzte richtung gibt es nicht
und freiheit scheint aber so ein
bisschen was wie das hier vorauszusetzen
nach einer bestimmten auffassung also
freiheit man könnte immer auch anders
handeln obwohl die bedingungen genau
dieselben sind freiheit also alternative
möglichkeiten
oder php des princes turner chief
possibilities das php
das liegt eigentlich der
freiheitsbegriff nahe so das ist jetzt
der zufall er sagt also das was mit dem
prinzip der alternativen möglichkeiten
ausgedrückt ist das habe ich jetzt eben
hinzugefügt das ist eigentlich zufall
und jetzt sagt er folgendes
interessanter kommentar ob durch die
kantige erklärung der transzendentalen
freiheit oder der absoluten spontanität
und durch den freilich künstlich genug
eingeleiteten versucht freiheit und
natur notwendigkeit miteinander zu
vereinigen der zufall vermieden oder
überhaupt einen mittelweg zwischen
notwendigkeit und zufall gefunden werden
können wird sich ausweisen als wir sehen
er kennt kann es theorie sehr gut
beschreibt die transzendentale freiheit
als absolutes mentalität und jetzt
spricht er von einer künstlich einem
künstlichen versuch freiheit unten ab
und notwendigkeit miteinander zu
vereinigen oder einen mittelweg zwischen
notwendigkeit und zufall zu finden
das unterstellt er jetzt kann ein
mittelweg zwischen zu finden zwischen
notwendigkeit und zufall
das muss natürlich kennt leisten um eine
überzeugende freiheits theorie zu
entwickeln hier sehen wir schon hier
wird er sehr kritisch gegen die bekannt
und da hat sich auch in der heutigen
diskussion euch nichts verändert der
termin ist und in der termin ist auch
hier sehen wir jetzt zum ersten mal
eigentlich in der geschichte der
philosophie wirklich diesen begriff des
in der termin ist und dass die
terminlisten also die
die begriffe sind in dieser debatte
geprägt worden in determinismus und
determinismus determiniert ist derjenige
welche lehrt dass alles was geschieht
seine entscheidenden gründe haben also
satz von zu reinen grunde folgt dass es
zu der zeit unter den gesamten beständen
die es da es geschieht nicht ausbleiben
oder schon jetzt anders sein konnte er
lehrt folgt eine wahre allgemeine
bedingte notwendigkeit auch in anziehung
unseres jedes maligen wollens oder
unsere vorsätze und entschließungen sie
mögen so regelmäßig und gut oder noch so
unvollkommen und mangelhaft sein als sie
wollen so konnten sie wenigstens jetzt
nach allen inhalt äußeren umständen noch
nicht anders zeigt all das ist der
termin ist da würden wir heute würden
die meisten auch zustimmen das war ein
termin ist bestimmt wird
jetzt sagt er hingegen was du in der
termin ist ist der in vitamin ist
hingegen bildet sich ein dass der
menschliche geist oder auch ein jedes
vernünftige wesen das vermögen besitzen
und da vollkommen denselben inneren und
äußeren umständen in vollkommen
demselben ganz unverändert gedacht
gesamten zustande wollen und nicht
wollen oder auch das gegenteil von dem
was er nun wirklich beschließen wollen
zu können dass jedes malige endliche
wollen hat demnach keine entscheidenden
und ist in dem verstanden ein jahr zuvor
ja also wenn man eben in gegenteilige
richtung entscheiden könnte dann wäre
man in der termin ist und dann würde man
eigentlich nur zufällig handeln und
nicht wirklich frei so im paragraf 9
kommt jetzt die hauptthese von ulrich es
gibt schlechterdings keinen mittelweg
zwischen notwendigkeit und zu fallen
und das hatte er jetzt kant unterstellt
dass kant eben einen mittelweg finden
wollte durch die unterscheidung von
dingen sicherheit erscheinungen und
durch diese trans and arlen kausalität
war jetzt schon mal wieder argumentieren
wenn ein vernünftiges wesen in einem
jetzigen ganz genau bestimmten zustand
etwas willen sich zu etwas entschließt
so hat es entweder und erfolg kommt
denselben inneren und äußeren umständen
auch die entschließung zu verlassen und
sich anders entschließen können oder
nicht es ist im ersten fall nicht ein
wahrer zufall dass sie anschließend
gerade so ausfällt da sieht doch bei
völlig ungehinderten zustande des
subjekts auch anders hätte ausfallen
können und habe mir nicht im zweiten
fall waren notwendigkeit so wenig
demnach zwischen zwei kontradiktorisch
entgegengesetzten gliedern ein drittes
geben kann was es heißen ebenso wenig
ist in den vorstellungen über die
sogenannten freien vorsätze und
entschließung einen mittelweg möglich
zwischen determinismus inter termin
ismus zwischen notwendigkeiten und
zufall also er sagt wir haben einfach
nicht die möglichkeit einen mittelweg zu
finden sondern wir müssen uns
entscheiden wollen wir jetzt terminiert
seien
oder wollen wir
wenn jetzt sein und die antwort die
berichte aufgibt ist wie wir gleich
sehen wir haben recht einfach er wird
sagen
im zweifel dann doch lieber determiniert
dass sein als in die dominiert deshalb
ja das ist so seine lösung und jetzt
interpretiert er noch mal kann es
versucht die freiheit der handlungen mit
ihrer durchgehend notwendigkeit zu
vereinigen und sagt dazu folgendes ich
finde deine sehr scharfsinnige
interpretation immer mehr ist mir
spinosa so schwer zu verstehen geworden
alles ist mir von jeher die stellen in
der kritik der reinen vernunft waren
welche die freiheit betreffen oft warum
sollte ich heute glaubte ich mich
wirklich in eine neue platonischen
schule versetzt unaussprechliche worte
und sachen zu hören
intelligent empirischer charakter eines
subjekts eine ursache deren kausalität
nicht anhebt obgleich ihre unmittelbare
wirkung anhebt die vernunft als der
intel gibt es vermögen und nach ihren
empirischen charakter und so weiter als
er versucht jetzt hier ein paar
widersprüche in der kritischen theorie
aufzuzeigen
kant ist sagte weiter von einer seite
betrachtet ein so strenger determiniert
in ansehung unsere entschließen und
handlungen er behauptet in ansehung der
selben eine so durchgängige entschieden
in den ton und wendigkeit als nur
irgendeiner das haben wir gesehen
erkannte ist alles selbst auch eine
freie handlung vollständig durch das
naturgesetz determiniert auf der anderen
seite aber ist ein solches sonderbares
neutrum das in anderer leos dass es carl
von linné ein naturforscher dass ein
anderen videos bei einer versuchten
klassifikation der philosophen selbst in
verlegenheit geraten würde
ob er ein dichter aus eine neue spezies
brachen zahle ja das finde ich sehr
pointiert das zitat also einerseits ist
kann ein völliger der termin ist
das haben wir gesehen in den letzten
sitzungen ich mache oben rechts nochmal
link rhein zu der sitzung wo diese
determination besprochen wurde
auf der anderen seite sagt jetzt gehe
ich ist ein sonderbares neutrum also
neutrum heißt keines von beiden also
etwas seltsames dass er gar nicht in das
raster passt also ist jetzt kommt ein
der termin ist oder ein in der termin
ist das ist die große frage und würde
ich sagt der kante passte irgendwie gar
nicht rein
der fällt aus dem rahmen und er kann
nicht irgendwie eingeordnet werden er
müsste eine neue spezies sein kannst du
das ja auch behaupten kann würde sagen
natürlich meine neues pc es heißt trans
zentrale philosophie die das bisher noch
nicht gar so weit kommt kann bestimmte
menschliche freiheit sagt ulrich weiter
als einfache würden sich unabhängig von
der nötigung durch sinnliche antriebe
und selbst zu bestimmen
das ist die definition und jetzt sagte
er folgendes einen kommentar dazu ich
wünschte das erkannt hier gleich
ausdrücklich und geradeheraus gesagt
hätte ob dies vermögen auch unabhängig
von allen anderen gründen die nicht
sämtliche antriebe nicht bloß
erscheinungen sind nicht der zeit nach
vorherigen angewendet werde oder nicht
aus den ersten gedanken scheint der
ausdruck von selbst im gleichen
absolutes mentalität zu führen den
anderen könnten mann
andere stellen sowohl in der kritik als
mir grundlegung zum mittag schickten
veranlassen
also jetzt kommt er auf diesen
schwierigen begriff der trans zentralen
kausalität zu sprechen und fragt jetzt
weiter wie die genau zu verstehen ist er
sagt nach dem intelligent character ob
wir wohl davon nichts als den
allgemeinen begriff haben können würde
dasselbe subjekt dennoch von allem
einflüsse der sinnlichkeit und
bestimmung durch erscheinungen
freigesprochen werden müssen
und da in ihm sofern es eine u min also
ging an sich ist nichts geschieht keine
veränderung weil die dynamische
zeitbestimmung erreichen mithin keine
verknüpfung mit erscheinen als ursache
angetroffen wird so würde dieses täter
gewesen insofern in seinen handlungen
von aller natur notwendigkeit als sie
lediglich in der sin welt angetroffen
wird unabhängig und frei sein
ja das soweit steht es dann zu einem
intelligenten charakter ob wir wohl
davon nichts als in allgemeinen begriff
haben können würde dasselbe objekt
dennoch von allem einflüsse jedem fall
gesprochen werden das ist das hat man
schon gesehen und jetzt sagt er unten
keine anderen veränderung als solche
gibt es doch wohl fühlen kann nicht oder
sollen wir uns etwa auch in tegel
veränderungen denken die nicht der
bedingung der zeit unterworfen sind also
der das problem ist folgendes kant hatte
gesagt auf der ebene des nomen uns der
dinge an sich findet keine veränderung
statt weil sie eben nicht derzeit
unterliegen nach dem raum weil das reine
anschauungs form sind jetzt ist es aber
doch so dass wir wenn wir uns frei
entscheiden durchaus operationen
vornehmen wie zum beispiel maximen
prüfung und so weiter und so fort
und dann müssten wir uns eigentlich
fragen ob nicht doch auch das in die
intelligent gewissen veränderungen
unterliegt die kant aber gerade
bestritten hat und das ist jetzt hier
dieses problem was jetzt hier unrecht
auf das ulrich hinweist er sagt und dem
so klappt kann werte freiheit natur
jedes in seiner vollständigen bedeutung
bei eben denselben handlungen je nachdem
wann sie mit ihrer intelligenten und
sensiblen usa vergleich zu gleich und
ohne widerspruch angetroffen werden
das ist jetzt so diese interpretation
und jetzt kommt hat die darstellung
jetzt kommt die beurteilung dieser these
von kant und jetzt versucht ulrich
bekannt dazu ein zu klassifizieren wie
es dieser linie gemacht hat in seiner
natur in seiner natur theorie wo alle
natürlichen arten neben ihren ort
bekommen hat jetzt sagt er ehrlich ist
also klar dass kanzlerin auf keine weise
mit in der termin ismus verwechselt
werden da denn anziehung der
erscheinungen und der handlung in
beziehung auf die empirischen charakters
menschen als von welcher seite der
determiniert inter termin ist ihm doch
allein zu betrachten pflegt wert er kann
die entschieden die notwendigkeit und
läutet alle freiheit in anziehung des
integrierten charakters aber hat er sich
auf eine so künstliche weise zu erklären
gewusst dass er von einer seite ebenso
wohl der natur notwendigkeit nach seinem
genau festzuhalten begriff als von der
anderen dem zufall
das heißt einem entstehen ohne
entscheidende gründe aus weit also jetzt
hier die kritik an kant wieder durch
eine künstliche reise hatte es zu
erklären gewusst dass beides miteinander
doch irgendwie kompatibel ist
ja das ist also dieser versuch des
inkompatibel ist kompatibles muss den
kant hier auch nach unternimmt und jetzt
sagt er weiter aber leugnung der natur
notwendigkeit im kantischen 10 uhr die
bestimmung durch erscheinung und durch
solche bedingungen welche
zeit nach vorheriger ausschließt so
bleibt immer die frage übrig ob nicht
dem intelligent character selbst gründe
der bestimmung des internets vermögen
sich finden welche zwar derzeit nach
nicht vorher gehen aber doch gründe war
wären auf welchen als danner torwände
notwendigkeit im anderen verstanden
stattfinden würde also jetzt die frage
muss wenn man jetzt die natur
notwendigkeit ausschließt für die freie
entscheidung weil sie ja nur im internet
stattfinden jetzt muss man fragen müssen
dann nicht durch auch im internet geben
also in dem internet was uns als die an
sich betrifft auch gründe sagt der
vorkommen
die eben nicht mehr zeit vorher gehen
weil sie nicht derzeit unterliegen aber
welche dann eben doch weil sie die sache
vollständig bestimmen natur
notwendigkeit in einem anderen
verstandes sind also haben wir dann doch
nicht wieder determinismus daneben dann
auch nicht diese freiheit die kanten
haben wollte nämlich ja auch immerhin
einen moment diese differenz enthalten
ja und das ist jetzt die kritik und ich
lese nochmals ins letzte tat vor was ich
ganz ganz zentral finden was die
kritiker und hält in dem bloß
intelligent character soll ein auch bloß
intel ihres vermögens seien ein zustand
von selbst anzufangen vermögen ein
anderes ist doch das vermögen ein
anderes die anwendung dieses vermögens
oder die unterlassung der anwendung von
welcher kann selbst redet die tadellos
würdigste handlung sei die unterlassung
der vernunft der unterlassung der wird
gänzlich beizumessen man sehe die
vernunft also eine ursache an
wie das verhalten des menschen
ungeachtet aller empirischen bestimmten
bedingungen auch anders habe bestimmen
können
und sollen also hier ist jetzt an dieser
stelle ist jetzt eben wieder sichtbar
und auch anders hier haben wir jetzt
diesen diese alternativen möglichkeit
die anwendung dieses vermögens dessen
anwendung unterlassen werden kann und
die unterlassung der anwendung welche
doch zur wahl stattfindet lässt sich
ohne zeitbestimmung ohne einen stehen
und anheben unmöglich denken überhaupt
sehe ich gar nicht sagt ulrich niemand
der frage ausweichen will warum und das
finde ich jetzt hier zentral warum wird
dieses vermögen bei gewissen handlung
angewendet also die vernunft andere
nicht entweder ist etwas vorhanden will
jetzt einmal der grund der anwendung an
anderen alten grund der unterlassung
enthält oder nicht
im ersten fall notwendigkeit im anderen
fall zu fall
also ulrich versteht jetzt nicht dass
scheint eine ganz zentrale kritik zu
sein
pikant jetzt erklären möchte im
zeitlosen des nominalen wie eben die
vernunft die auf unsere freiheit und
auch für die moralität zuständig ist wie
die einmal aktiv wird im moralisch guten
handlung und wie sie in moralischen
handlung eben gerade nicht aktiv wird
wie sie also unterlassen wird das
bedeutet auch im intelligenten bereich
muss eine veränderung stattfinden können
alle die vernunft muss einmal aktiviert
werden können einmal nicht und diese
veränderung die selbst wiederum zeit
voraus und das hatte kannte ja gerade
bestritten als eben das telegenen
angelangt also wir haben eben entweder
nur zufall oder notwendigkeit und jetzt
sagte er folgendes ist vielleicht
unterlassung der 15 ursprünglich ein
unveränderlicher mangel der tätigkeit
5 eine schwäche intelligente charakter
und anwendung der vernunft an
ursprünglicher und unveränderlicher
zustand einer höheren tätigkeit und
wirksamkeit zu haben ja mit der
unveränderlichkeit hinter den charakter
des notwendigkeit und gleich nicht nur
natur notwendigkeit im chaotischen
szenen
die empirische charakter aber ist
notwendigkeit ist notwendig im internet
gegründet als auch hier notwendigkeit
also überall notwendigkeit also er sagt
auch bekannt haben wir eigentlich nur
notwendigkeit und dieses moment diese
alternativen möglichkeiten was kant
angenommen hatte das gibt es nicht die
vernunft hat kausalität und anziehung
unsere handlungen was heißt der vernunft
man redet von einer objektiven fünft
diese ist freilich unendlich sowie die
wahrheit unveränderlich ist da entsteht
nichts entgeht nichts unter sie die
vernunft bleibt von ewigkeit zu ewigkeit
dieselbe aufgabe ist hier nicht von
demselben abstraktum wie dies medial
dass sein konkurrierenden gegenstand nur
in gott finden würde die rede sondern
bei kann zeigt jetzt ruhig von einer
subjektiven vernunft dass die vernunft
und kausalität habe wenigstens wir uns
alle der gleichen an ihr vorstellen ist
aus den imperativen klar welche viren
allen praktischen den ausüben kräften
als regeln aufgeben also übrig
kritisiert kannst begriff der vernunft
als eine objektive vernunft die keinen
wandel kennt und die eben auch immer
einige aufs gute ausgerichtet sein
müsste und jetzt sagt eben unterricht
und zur vernunft ist nicht immer nur
aufs klo ausgerichtet sie hat durchaus
auch mal schwächen oder 40 und das
bedeutet wieder unter als objektive
fünftes und nicht die reine praktische
von der kant gesprochen hatte
die unveränderte in der vernunft nun die
allen handlungen des menschen in allen
zeitungsständen gegenwärtig und
von welcher jede wirkliche handlung die
unmittelbare wirkung welche selbst nicht
in der zeit seien nicht in einen neuen
zustand geraten zur darin sie vorher
nicht wahr
wie kann sie gleichwohl so ganz
verschiedene willkommen zu verschiedenen
zeiten in der erscheinung hervorbringen
kann hatte die these vertreten dass die
vernunft immer absolut ist nah diese
absolute ursache dass die unverändert
bei der veränderung wiederum zeitbedarf
und das ist ja im intelligenten markant
gerade nicht der fall als wie kann dann
aber diese vernunft die doch eigentlich
und zeitlich ist und die doch eigentlich
absolut ist wie kann sie gleichwohl so
ganz verschiedene wirkungen zu
verschiedenen zeiten in der erscheine
vorbringen dh auch in den bereich der
verlust irgendwie eine veränderlichkeit
vorhanden sein und das würde aber wieder
eine gewisse form von zeitlichkeit
voraussetzen
ja das ist also so die freunde von
ulrich wir werden auch in den nächsten
17 nochmal genau darüber sprechen wir
werden dann auch noch eine rezension von
kant lesen der dieseltechnologie
kritisiert hat auch ein gewisser herr
kraus der von kant dazu angeleitet wurde
hat sich sehr kritisch mit leute
biologie befasst